ó pá boninho
[Música]
portugal está acabando os ingressos em
europa nem eu nem vou falar nada disso
não perde seu tempo para japão já acabou
com o estudo ea áfrica já está minada
tem eu só tenho a vocês ingresso no meu
site
vocês falam em 2009 cresceu tanto como
foi essa não sou um cara pra vocês
aos 28 o caso aqui
[Música]
que pariu desgraça e aí agora que o
ronaldo que vocês meu amigo hoje não foi
o dia começa a gravar vídeo não viu essa
luz ao cabelo conta agora com muito
esforço tem o enredo negócio já vem
montar se aperta e saem à luz acabou meu
deus de 1967 em um calor do cara ai que
está aqui em são paulo eu não entendo
porque todo dia e chove só que achou de
são paulo é igual o vândalo ela parece
só para derrubar usava os postes agora
spianato gravando desde 7 horas da manhã
eu cheguei em casa feliz para gravar um
vídeo que eu mudo cenário eu conclui e
peso na bosta num colete de repente é
mais aqui estamos nós nem sabe que
estamos rumo à placa derrube na época da
apae
clique em inscrever se inscreva no canal
você está vivendo pela primeira vez seja
bem vindo a este canal e clique em
inscrever se você já escrito que não vai
pegar o vídeo que você mais gostou que
acha engraçado a mandar pra alguém
whatsapp vai pedir a pessoa se inscrever
no canal para análise uma placa de
cumprir 150 milhões de inscritos
conseguir essa placa nós vamos uma ela e
nós vamos conseguir
motivador em jamaicana gostei também de
equipe você já viu no título tem muita
gente falando isso porque tu faz vídeos
em negócios euclides henrique em seu quê
de pol pot porque machuca eu comecei a
ganhar dinheiro de quatro anos pra cá
então tem quatro anos eu tenho dinheiro
ou antes disso os outros 20 anos e eu
falava célebre o cabeleireiro para ligar
a tv no nível quero chegar onde você não
dá pra esquecer enraizado em mim e
quando eu vou das situações a minha
cabeça ela começa a fazer essas
comparações e deu um exemplo a seguir
aconteceu uma coisa fazer um tipo muito
tempo que não tinha acontecido comigo e
aí eu fui eu comecei com o pará entendeu
e foi o velório foi na minha cabeça
começou meu amigo valor do ritmo
diferente o valor do pobre isso e muito
anos a começar pela causa da morte
a começar pela causa da morte ea causa
da morte do rico acervo não bonita
senhora os palácios infelizmente
tentando salvar o seu marido mas ele
morreu de massachusetts a morte de pobre
é show vai tomar banho sai moeda é botar
negócio a tomar é queda de moto ou não
mas foi o caso de mamãe noel fica
empinado diabo do final dessa marca é um
mal faltou talvez um premiando vale meu
deus aonde no crânio receber a notícia à
família do rico é muito diferente não
tenha lá não falou no vídeo falou outro
que olha pouco a pouco ele falou que
olhe para o outro ele parou no final
todo mundo chega à conclusão que já
sabia e acontecer é triste ele se fui
mal foi melhor assim o papo começa às
vezes pela televisão e humilhante olha
você clicar no balãozinho cidade agora
vendia chegamos aqui agora no local do
crime
o jovem encontra-se esfaqueado aqui no
chão e se eu tô vive ajuda que ele é
ladrão não se o pt foi um enfarte olha
que moradores locais e indignados aqui
com a situação aí o descaso a tiro um
homem firme a sua casa eu se acampe me
ajuda que é votar e pedí agoniza de
pedir ajuda dos dados pessoas trazer
onde olhos transeunte fácil a vergonha
quem achava ajudar ninguém e gente
morreu o homem está morrendo aqui agora
ao fim
ai ai o descaso como a senhora me ajuda
aqui pelo amor de deus que todo o
programa de meio dia
já 11 beijar não aconteceu nenhuma
desgraça hoje a fai o oxi pessoal está
em casas e não vi uma pessoa motor
addemeer não moça agora quando conta com
um pólo pessoalmente meu amigo alerta
parece que chamaram o corpo de bombeiros
[Risadas]
as crianças nas escolas
ao todo já leva pensando na hora do
recreio horas e 10 horas da manhã
a fábrica para o trabalhador vão lançar
o regime mulher e toda família recebe a
notícia de moto é alguém que chama
rejane eu não sei porque a rejane ela
tentava consolar sinal maria a hora de
enterrar o rei comigo não tem conversa
engenheiro 1015 minuta pronta encerrar
já é papo no rio o enterro não tem
conversa se nesses quinze minutos para
acordar e fala gente eu tô vivo os
parentes onde repousa assim cima pode
ver notícia de morte de ricas sempre
assim mário alberto de alencastro famoso
cirurgião plástico das estrelas morreu
esta madrugada de infarto no miocárdio
agudo será perto de massas schutz hora
da morte foi confirmada às 13 e 14 da
manhã o corpo foi velado às três e 45 os
parentes já estão em casa tranquilo de
boa dormir nos parentes e amigos da
família estão de luto em nos motiva o
pobre até chegar ao feito disse que tem
espalhado pelo brasil não pode ter raiva
do projeto de deus no brasil da são
paulo da manaus a amar essa foto foi
levantar e falar rapaz eu soubesse que
era assim eu tinha morrido só daqui um
mês na hora do velório o caixão na
vitória do rico para temas que parecem a
geladeira a geladeira se deitar tóquio
já porque é que vai decidir frisei a
bela expressão scania na câmara dos
deputados na época no teatro famoso da
cidade onde o pobre na sala de casa ele
tem um jeito que só a honra menino que
só por mais uma creche no momento o leão
primeiro contato da criança com amor tá
doido lembra primeira vez que eu fui no
velório da criança é doida e tão
aterrorizado que ficar dizendo ah sim
para minha mãe é mãe
brinca na mãe mãe do cachorro mesmo
caixão de todos o tempo do meu deus do
céu era igual mas só troca a pessoa fica
esperando morrer para o falecido com um
blush medonho que parece que tirou fotos
com flash e willame quem calou do carro
muita gente muita mas muita gente que
está ali só para ver um morto pela
primeira vez você conhece a pessoa que
foi morto a primeira vez porque todos
depois que permite olhar falei aqui a
maioria eu fui eu arrumo dg tomando chá
e comer um creme claro que meu deus eu
acho que eu nunca vi tanta gente junta
do mesmo lugar como em crónica como
veloz que a renda que segura crack é o
velório de cachorro que só por moto táxi
ou então a muvuca junto ao toque e
foquei matar foi matar matar foi matar
matar foi matar botafogo vai ter facada
o choro rico amigo choro dele parece que
ela acabou de papai noel sorológica só
assim chega perto do caixão e jeans
finalmente você está em paz a glória ao
custo luiz anexos amigo rico consola
você entende que foi melhor pra ele não
entende cassandra o pobre só repete o
nome
maxwell
quanto mais feio não mas ele gosta de
repetir o meu melhor a missa de sétimo
dia vai terminar no oitavo dia de tanto
repetir meu nome e tenta consolá lo
melhor
meu amor ideia melhor pra que lhe
facilitou o contato mas foi deus que diz
assim decidiu colocar na mesa onde pelo
amor de deus ela vai querer investir o
fármaco no céu só pagar trabalho as
conversas no velório que eu vi ele falar
e se equipara em ondas já viu algum
tempo colocando meu caro o informe -
penso na minha família
no palco ele chega e fala assim horas
foi não sei que havia interesse é que
ele gosta de saber que obra foi quem
sofreu o pior foi a saber pra que
trabalha na funerária hora que ora foi
eu queria saber como é que se prolonga
começa a ver se a pessoa respondesse
falar assim ele morreu é 1325 tamanho é
aquela pessoa vai responder por dispensa
conversa ela vai dizer o que a mãe
morreu no frio né não carol naquelas foi
essa altura do campeonato o valor do
pobre a avó da família tapeba de remédio
mechak tupi essa mulher é aumentar só
existindo esse último valor que eu fui
eu tô contando a história foi meu avô e
recebendo disse estava subindo no palco
para fazer show a minha mãe estava nesse
show meu pai tava todo mundo lá e aí
todo mundo voltou e como eu já subi no
palco eu tive que fazer um show e
naquele show ali para a retirada das
pessoas tudo foi tão contagiante que eu
falei cara acho que é por isso que eu
quero fazer um gol na minha vida eu
descobri que o motor tem uma força muito
grande pra ajudar a pessoa a cara e aí
eu tornei um dia que seriam muito
literalmente a desgraça pra mim
em um dia que poxa eu fiquei tranqüilo
fiquei feliz acer jt wang tão bonita
assim tá brincando de boca do cachorro
como se pensar nisso ficar acho que
tenham contato com as pessoas para que
tenham gostado vídeo se você tiver
gostado porque gostei está não esquece
de se inscrever no canal rumo a 50
milhões para pegar a placa de ruby
beleza é nóis valeu e melhor